Aloha rejects Greg here and Kyle we're
gonna watch the rogue one the Star Wars
story this is a featurette Kyle is a
Star Wars fan I love Star Wars and I
have seen all the Star Wars movies
including the Clone Wars movie but I
became a show you're gonna say all four
of them okay cool yeah I've seen all
five Star Wars this will be the sixth
one of them not mistake I'm normally not
the biggest feature that kind of guy I
don't know I kind of feel like watching
too much that especially before movie
comes out it tends to feel like it's
kind of ruining some of the magic for me
of a film yeah III agree with that I
can't help myself I still look good I
mean no one can abuse it yeah let's see
what they have to offer I mean it's like
two minutes so can't be a lot expose
here
[Music]
whoa right these films he's gotta do the
story if you feel everyone in the career
in the class come stops and just take
that in and you remember oh actually in
Star Wars she's gorgeous
it's like the world's greatest toy said
kid again
the Star Wars figures don't trip is over
here and this happens in explosion OH
okay takes place very close to Episode
four nice way to explain it is that text
you see at the beginning of a new hope
[Music]
that was essentially moving
[Music]
terrible weapon
Jim starting to put together a team was
the fight we will do all men are doing
this great journey when you see the
formation of the Rebel Alliance and
stealing the Death Star plans
they achieve what they achieve because
they achieve it together
whoo I cannot wait oh my god that looks
great you know I'm seeing it so hard
it's not even funny
I really believe the enthusiasm and
passion when they cuts like the director
the actors and they're talking about how
like how much they love being like it
seems genuine they don't seem like
they're trying to oversell their
enthusiasm for it it seems very genuine
they really are happy to be involved on
the surface I always say every film is
ultimately made because people want to
make money but there is often movies
that are made out of passion and this
one regardless if there's money to be
made or not this one is made out of
passion it means that it's likely going
to be an amazing film I mean it's Star
Wars it's not gonna suck well it's a
it's a hybrid of this isn't gonna suck
wanting to make money I highly doubt it
I highly doubt it I mean I think
director Gareth Edwards is a really good
director and I feel like he knows how to
create tension in films and suspense and
he also knows how to bring human
characters to life when he did Godzilla
a lot of people really liked it despite
I might feel like God's a little barely
being in it a lot of people really like
so unprofessionally Yan while we're
recording deal with this with John all
the time so you guys think that like
forgiveth us make a Godzilla 2 hour
movie where he's barely in it you have
to make all the human characters
interesting as well yeah and he managed
to do that and I feel like here we're
getting it's a new set of characters we
don't know the outcome of who's really
gonna live and who's gonna die like a
lot better theorizing they're all
probably gonna die yeah regardless
though I love that you know that you got
these new cares I'm actually intrigued
by to see cuz when I first heard like
this is what the story is about the
rebels stealing the plans look this is
this really seemed like a necessary
movie and the more I see in this film
you could feel a genuine love for Star
Wars behind the camera in front of the
camera all of it and in some ways you
get to go back into that world more so
than even you're gonna do with the new
sequels that are coming yeah cuz it's
the it's a pre post right before the
first star 4.5 yeah or right before it
yeah it's like yeah it's right after
three it's after three but right before
yeah and I think that's a great that's a
great way to revisit this stuff you know
like I want Star Wars just to continue
expanding and not only play to our
nostalgia factor cuz my force awakens
was a lot of nostalgia sure this is
definitely a lot of nostalgia sure they
got their Han Solo Sheriff going on it's
true I heard that this will not have an
opening scroll like all the other Star
Wars films and I'm okay with that yeah
some people are upset by but I want this
film to be its own thing as much as
possible that because yeah you don't
want this to feel like it's another one
of the episodes it is different it's not
the CI Walker clan I mean there's Darth
Vader but it's it's like a whole new
cast and there's yeah it's it's it's a
separate story from the linear timeline
story of the like yeah Skywalker and who
knows if it's so great I mean maybe this
will even have a continuation on its own
yeah I mean I'd be cool I don't think
they're aiming to do nap but no that's
over either like we should try to do it
under well yeah if there's more story to
tell somewhere and it's worth telling
then you know I think yes but I'm a huge
Star Wars fan so I would just watch it
all I hate this movie has to be so good
in the journey not its destination
because you know they succeed in getting
the plan and should be an interesting be
kind of cool to see like what they do
with whoever survives if some with one
of these people on the main crew
survives and if they go into like one of
the later Star Wars films like Episode
eight or another spin-off film that
would be crazy
that me nuts boom or if they're already
in one of the other movies and we don't
know that we don't know it yeah yeah
it's part of their plan already that'd
be cool alright well yeah that's sweet
cut it's only a couple of weeks away if
you're new to the channel reject
subscribe today get accepted title
either demands on all the social media
clapping is annoying and videos makes a
distracting noise every time especially
the latter you do it or if you punch
outro